[Musique]
il est là il va se préparer il va
rentrer puisque bertrand chamerois est
avec nous bertrand chamerois vous le
savez il a quitté s'est vite pour aller
sur w9
regardez bertrand xinhua c'est ça il
sera sur le fauteuil dans un instant
pour le conseil de famille at il bien
fait de quitter ses 8 oui ou non c'est
parti bertrand chamerois c'est ça sans
transition la météo bas demain il fera
beau à certains endroits moche à
d'autres et puis de toute façon je m'en
fous du temps puisque vous êtes juste là
pour mater mais bulls
en charmeur mois celle au transfert de
l'été vous avez fait le job des vannes
des punchline est basique j'embrasse
roselyne bachelot on l'a vu tout à
l'heure vous avez les biens
[Musique]
au fait est ce qu'on l'a oublié fait
roule à oublier jean marie le pen fait
on ne l'a pas oublié
anouk ensuite inauguré le salon des
vents le problème c'est qu'après l'expo
by un discours consommation mondiale par
leur régularisation
d'ores et déjà ce que tu as fait avoir
comme conséquence
[Applaudissements]
gamin qui lisent très bien la sur
médiatisation qui est due au succès de
l'émission ça n'est pas mon cas et
aujourd'hui je ressens le besoin de
prendre du recul par rapport à tout ça
m
les bons vieux
[Musique]
même
g
notre invité ce soir à nice
[Applaudissements]
je vois très bien et bien là c'est
confort c'est bien tu vas bien je suis
très celui-là tu pars avec merci mon
bertrand d'être là c'est qu'on aura de
nicolas dupont aignan aussi rythme tu
reste avec nous bien sûr reste avec nous
tu pense qu'on va envahir bien pour le
moment on va avoir l'avis des
téléspectateurs
l'avis des chroniqueurs est ce que
bertrand a bien fait d'aller sur w9 et
et de quitter ce voilà ce qui restera
toujours sa famille parce qu'on se
retrouve pouvoir toujours revenir notre
fan oui je sais que ce soit sur s'est
vite sur canal+ sur ses stars ou encore
sûr c'est nous avec jean pierre
elkabbach je pense que tu as ta science
et que tu as ta place mais ça je vais
aller partout toi bah oui mais je te dis
bertrand tu restes avec nous on fera ça
dans un instant est ce que vous êtes
prêts les chéris oui alors avant qu'on
parle de bertrand et avant que vous nous
disiez si bertrand a bien fait ou pas de
quitter ses huit pour w9
à votre avis voilà vous nous le donnera
j'aimerais qu'on voit quelques moments
forts de la chronique de bertrand on
s'est fait un petit en avant par est
alors il ya eu un doute c'était l'année
dernière vous aviez piégé bfm tv ah oui
le jour de la rentrée scolaire mois plus
tôt ben oui oui bah on avait pris
l'appel à témoins et on s'était fait
passer pour enfin je m'étais fait passer
pour un enfant
non mais ça et regarder de temps pour un
enfant de 7 ans bertrand regardez bien
ça c'était magnifique c'était vraiment
sur bfm tv et le gard l'ariège n'a rien
vu fait partie a regardé matisse il ya
trois enfants dans la famille qui vous
accueille ce matin on en est où eh ben
on en est au petit déjeuner pour
l'instant regarder le petit raphaël qui
rentrera la crèche tout à l'heure et
voilà le plus grand qui se lève à
l'instant vous voyez le réveil est en
cours pour l'instant ici poser une
petite question papa quand même eu le
réveil et le petit déjeuner on prend
quoi pour être bien au bas des fruits
des l'état
des biscuits et puis après des chocapics
mais je sais pas si on a des chocapics
ou pas non on n'a pas de chocapic
malheureusement mais sinon moyenne tu
peux tout de l'eau alors insulté de
tisane voilà vous avez compris le petit
déjeuner va se faire doucement la
rentrée elle est prévue pour 9h je suis
bien sûr et avait fait qu'on a vraiment
rien de fabuleux le matin sur bfm tv est
également bien sûr sur ces news et sur
lci les informations c'est important et
on docteur de l'information tous les
jours bertrand y avait un autre de
soucis qu'on avait adoré c'était cap sur
gags soit la caméra cachée les plus
pourris en fait le l'histoire la télé
c'était formidable et on voulait les
revoir ce soir d'un prochain le roi
c'était ça aussi
pis dans ce nouveau numéro de gak sur
gago aujourd'hui nous allons piéger un
restaurant asiatique bonjour ça serait
pour des pénale arrabiata
non de benarbia tas à ses côtés c'était
une caméra cachée
bravo à tous ces pourris gâtés le garage
merci direction maintenant est ce salon
de coiffure une baguette pas trop cuite
si vous avez bravo c'était une caméra
cachée
franck leroy que tu avec nous ce soir
bon bertrand monde à franges ou est ce
là une petite interview l'ex avant qu'on
fasse le débat qu'elle est l'ex de tpm
pettitte manque le plus jean luc lemoine
jean luc lemoine cdc normal ben moi
aussi même quand il est moins il me
manque kelly l'ex de type respect qui te
manque le moins
matthieu delormeau qu'elle est l'ex que
tpm paix qui mériteraient comme vous de
voler de ses propres ailes
gilles verdez une verdeur vision qu'elle
est l'ex de tmp qui vous reste le plus
fidèle et qui continue à apprendre de
vos nouvelles thierry moreau d'accord
merci pour moi mais non mais parce que
j'ai des ports chroniqueur ça me fait
beaucoup de peine quand même autour de
la table parmi des nouvelles recrues
féminines qui auriez-vous bien aimé
avoir comme ex magath a gâté va très
bien et bien elle et elle est là faites
vous plaisir mon bertrand c'est vrai
qu'on a passé des moments fabuleux avec
toi tu es maintenant sur w9 et bertrand
ils vont dire si tu as bien fait de
partir ou pas vous décidez également
chez vous si le fauteuil reste comme ça
oui c'est que tu as bien fait de partir
sur w9 si le fauteuil se retourne c'est
que les téléspectateurs pensent que tu
aurais dû rester sur ces 8 alors
attention on va démarrer par benjamin
castaldi
il ne connaissait pas bien comment puis
je me suis alors je vais devenir un mal
à aimer beaucoup dans tpm b je pense
qu'il a bien fait quand on vous propose
une émission à vous sur une chaîne et il
n'y a pas de raison de refuser
c'est dommage qu'il ait plutôt pas
rester sur ces vite qu'ils aient pas
fait quelque chose de ses propres ailes
sur s'est vite mais honnêtement je pense
qu'il a fait un très bon choix
d'accord quand même caroline ithurbide
alors moi j'aime beaucoup bertrand
chamerois ce que je trouve que c'est un
garçon très touchant jeu très contente
qui vole de ses propres ailes et je
comprends cette espèce de désir
d'émancipation mais pour moi il est
parti trop tôt il me fait penser un
petit peu à un enfant qui aurait quitté
son papa vous et sa maman ses huit un
peu trop vite à vous êtes vous croyez
que je gagne 6,8 en fait ben écoutez je
sais pas si je vous dis qu'elle est
celle du tout
jean-luc déjà moi je veux dire que c'est
une grosse perte pour touche pas à mon
poste il n'a pas été remplacé et on se
rend compte que c'est difficile de faire
une rubrique quotidienne et les fabuleux
il
mais on avait une chaufferie et camille
bertrand pacé race qui était super rare
maintenant on a heureusement et ascq
amis mais il faut que tu aies me reste
donc ça on n'a pas remplacé mais
maintenant il avait une rubrique de dix
minutes on lui propose une émission
complète et où il peut faire ce qu'il
veut c'est voir exposées il faut prendre
aussi toutes les 8 bien sûr c'est moins
exposés évidemment mais je pense aussi
qui fait ses armes comme ça et après il
ira ailleurs
donc je pense qu'il a bien fait et en
plus je crois que w9 fait confiance
jean-michel merde oui moi je trouve
qu'il a pris une belle décision parce
que surtout il avait un boulevard sur w9
parce que j'y réfléchissais un peu juste
avant et j'essaye de trouver des
animateurs de w9 qui soit vraiment
attaché à la chaîne pas d'étonner jorion
sur m6 qui viennent de temps en temps il
y en a pas d'autres dons que bertrand il
a du talent il est jeune donc il lui
font confiance donc il a tout l'avenir
devant lui sur w9
donc il ya aucune raison qu'ils
réussissent pas et voilà je suis sûr
qu'il est là il a pris la bonne décision
benjamin rabier du grand direct des
médias oui pour moi aussi c'est une
bonne décision parce que il est jeune il
est talentueux et que sur w9 jeu jusqu'à
l'année dernière avait pas grand chose
avait pas d'animateur lui a proposé
d'être le visage de w9 pour la rentrée
2016-2017 nos coûts il a fait un bon
choix ou oui c'est compliqué en ce
moment parce que c'est moins exposée que
je peux à mon pass mais oui pour moi est
un bon choix et les jeunes faut tenter
un stage là je compte bien sûr mathieu
mais moi je sens qu'il a il a vraiment
très bien fait la preuve c'est qu'il
manque à tpm pcr qu'il est parti au
moment où il fallait sans doute avant la
saison de trop selon cela s'est un petit
peu de surpoids sur w9 cette émission et
on serait bien
[Rires]
continue donc de surcroît l'émission
tout devenait donc elle est très très
bien très bien produite pour moi c'est
devenu sa ya alors un pacte c'est jérôme
revon le reste je dirais pour moi c'est
devenu un rendez vous sauf qu'il est
jeune il réussit bien son taux alors un
rendez vous je vous dire moi c'est le
seul truc qui je vais dire la vérité
ouais c'est j'adore w9 ont plus vous
savez et le groupe m6 on est vraiment
très très proches voilà eux et moi on
s'aime beaucoup il ya un seul problème
c'est que je ne comprends pas quand
passent les missions une fois c'est le
mardi
une fois ces dimanche et ne pourra non
plus même si c'est que je comprends pas
le concept qu'il a tellement changé
voilà c'est le seul reproche qu'on
pourrait pas les enseignes et là ils
sont kelly là le lac concept est calé
mais moi c'est juste l'horaire je ne
suis en rien à l'horaire d'ofni une
poche le voile dimanche soir en prime
time le voile mardi soir après la
semaine dernière je vous jure que c'est
vrai j'ai appelé le producteur qui est
mon pote stéphane gâteau jeudi dix mois
jaton sni là ça va arriver ou pas
emiliano l'on n'y a pas cette semaine ah
ok pourquoi jean-pierre bertrand vous
comprenez la programmation vous non
merci non pas du tout voilà c'est vrai
je connais c'est comme pour connaître
ses à w9 même quand ils les échecs en
prime ils continuent d'investir sur lui
je pense qu'il donne à deux ans vraiment
pour voir un vrai vrai visage
il est jeune je pense qu'il faut
vraiment vraiment compter sur lui se
débrouille très bien et moi je pense
qu'il a vraiment pris la bonne décision
agathe ou prou oui je pense que c'est
carrément l'une des meilleures décisions
de sa jeune et brillante carrière parce
que j'avais rencontré bertrand cantat
juste avant le week-end avec m
bayrou mais j'avais rencontré berton
juste avant le lancement d'ofni et deux
choses la première est comparé sa sortie
de tpm paix à la sortie du premier loft
ce qui a été pris dans ce tourbillon
médiatique que peut être les missions et
ça ça lui ça commençait à coûter
énormément il savait plus très bien
comment le gérer donc ils avaient besoin
de s'en sortir et il a su très bien le
faire parce que au fini c'est une
émission qu'il a réfléchi pensé et
imaginé avec ces équipes c'est pas un
format qu'on lui a imposée c'est un
format que lui apporter et qui lui va je
trouve très bien
il avait alors pareil tu te sois tu
disais qu'il supporte plus la pression
dont il est parti il avait pas il
n'avait pas le choix je mens kim je
trouve qu'il manque beaucoup à tpm paix
ils sont l'association avec camille
combal la saison
[Rires]
la solution il faut aussi du saucisson
voilà donc quantité des solutions
ensemble c'était génial d'acquitter
grâce au décret alors oui et donc ouais
moi là dedans et j'ai su persuader que
w9 pardon w9 mais je suis persuadé que
c'est une étape transitoire même si
c'est le visage le visage de la chaîne
pour un visage il n'est pas très très
exposé un et je trouve comme vous qui a
un manque total de visibilité sur cette
émission que je n'arrive jamais à choper
et je pense que vous retravailleraient
ensemble
j'en suis absolument convaincu donc
c'est une étape transitoire pour moi
jules bertrand a commis une grave erreur
aa je lui demande solennellement de
revenir pour trois raisons première
raison il est parti trop tôt oui ça
allait pas il en avait marre mais il
aurait dû prendre six mois de pause 6
mois sabbatiques et revenir après à la
rentrée ça aurait été super on a cru toi
au plus on a tout entendu sur le départ
de bertrand c'est vraiment bertrand tu
peux parler la battait même pas besoin
de leur tournée on dirait qu'on a tout
entendu
mais je vous dis la vérité on le redit
encore ce soir bertrand et moi on
n'était pas du tout fâché on s'est parlé
dans l'alcool
il m'a dit voilà c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de pression tout ça et on n'est
rien on sait on sait au téléphone ont
gelé pratiquement toutes les semaines au
téléphone bertrand ou par sms
tu dis ça va petit cul tout ça il vous
répond voilà voilà donc non mais la
chance deuxième raison c'est quand il a
de la chose ah oui et je vous ai répondu
heureux texto deuxième raison sa
chronique je suis entièrement d'accord
avec jean luc là au moment de la
présidentielle serait un régal il savait
super bien détourné l'actu aurait été
génial
et troisièmement s'il avait été là ils
auraient pris son élan vous l'auriez
aider et c'est sans doute lui qui
présenteraient à la place de mathieu il
en pense quoi calmy rey vendredi et ça
ce serait un bonheur pour tout le monde
c'est donc vous êtes un visionnaire il a
pris la bonne décision parce qu'il a
pris la décision avec son coeur et je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'on prend des
bonnes décisions et en choeur ils en un
énorme en il aurait pu choisir la
facilité en continuant sa rubrique il
fonctionnait très bien il a pris un
risque en allant sur un nouveau rendez
vous une nouvelle émission
donc bravo le seul truc c'est que ces
tchèques en milieu d'émission me manque
parce qu'on se check à chaque fois qu'il
rentrait sur le plateau voilà et c'est
un
l'analyse patron donc merci merci
thierry moreau c'est fini bertrand on
bertrand var var est plein il va dire ce
qu'il en pense oui il en a pris plein la
gueule là mon bertrand rochette alors
déjà je voudrais tous vous remercier
parce que ces adorables tout ce que vous
venez de dire est donc merci ça me
touche profondément
où ça à diverses parties de mon être et
non mais je suis d'accord avec tout ce
que vous avez dit puisque vous ça résume
assez bien ma pensée bien sûr que vous
manquez que la folie de l'émission me
manque mais j'ai effectivement pris
cette décision avec mon coeur que je
savais que ce serait pas déjà je suis
pas parti pour w9 je suis parti pour
tout arrêter et j'ai eu la proposition
ensuite
et effectivement je suis moins exposé je
m'éclate je fais ce que je veux
aujourd'hui donc je suis je suis très
heureux mais vous vous manqué aussi
c'est bien mais pas trop de bévues pas
trop de fin à cette phrase ménage c'est
pas grave c'est là on a l'habitude dans
cette émission
merci bertrand bertrand aura ce qu'on
pense les téléspectateurs est ce que
bertrand a bien fait de partir sur w9 ou
pas s'ils se retourne
si le fauteuil se retourne c'est que
vous auriez mieux fait de rester dans
l'émission s'il faut te retourne pas
c'est que vous avez bien fait de partir
loin de tout ça c'est parti
[Musique]
ah oui les gens pensent conseil
c'est parce que les jaunes et vertes
installez-vous un côté mathieu bertrand
chamerois qui étaient avec nous et oui
les gens pensent que vous auriez dû
rester bertrand mais c'est pas grave
voilà vous êtes toujours un petit peu
avec nous et peut-être qu'un jour vous
reviendrez à nos côtés en tout cas sur
ces huit puisque vous avez dit qu'on
vous manque d'insérer la chaîne vous
manquent mais il vous manque et la
chaîne me manque aussi puis c'est la
famille quoi on sait pas ce qui peut se
passer demain
julien on sait même pas ce qui peut se
passer dans une heure là du point jeunes
qui sera avec nous dans un instant en
tout cas merci mais merci à mr vraiment
d'être venus aider
[Applaudissements]